so is amazon moving away from brad and
brad wright's project for stargate and
does it really matter do we care
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so if you are regular side tracking
you'll know that i recently did a video
about how uh mark ferguson hawk ostby
who has the greatest name ever i i need
my first name to be hawk
call me horg from now on i want lots
lots of comments calling me hawk please
but um that there are being tapped up to
maybe develop a new stargate series but
what does that mean for brad wright
well as we know brad wright has a vision
for a new stargate series he has
actually written a script um that's been
had several months of development mgm
were very very close to green light in
that script but amazon pulled the plug
brad wright himself has actually said
that he no longer believes that it's
very likely that that script will ever
actually get made so
is it dead
is this news that potentially hawke and
mark are being approached to develop a
new series the final nail in the coffin
so this is based on my opinion this is a
rumor that mark ferguson horcos b have
been approached to do this i'm hoping we
will find out and very shortly whether
it's true or not but
if it is true
what do i think well i know um and i've
been telling you guys for nine months
that amazon were never that happy with
brad wright's project and branch
wright's vision they love him as a
writer they adore him as a writer
they've asked him to do all the projects
including uh to write a script from an
unannounced movie potentially for amazon
so it's not his writing ability that's
in question it was just the vision of
where he wanted to take stargate in the
future amazon executives don't agree
so as i've told you before what i'm told
was amazon was always actually going to
be the customer for mgm to buy stargate
they were involved from day one pushing
mgm in a certain direction and trying to
get brad wright to follow that direction
brad wright was apparently told
repeatedly to think a lot bigger and
that's the word that the guy i spoke to
used
in his vision for stargate
amazon wanted something a little bit
different and to go in a little bit of a
different direction and according to
what i'm being told brad wright's
project looked a little bit too much
like the original stargate series rather
than something
a bit fresher and a bit more modern so
the position that we're in
is basically that amazon have never
particularly liked brad right's project
and so to be honest it was probably
never going to get made
mgm believed even just a few months ago
that they were going to have creative
free reign and that amazon were only
going to really act as a customer that
naive opinion got smashed very quickly
when the two executives in charge of mgm
both quit or were pushed so that's the
position we're in right now the brad
rights project is probably pretty much
dead but does it mean brad's right's
involvement is dead well what i'm being
told is that mark and hawke are being
approached to develop a new series
develop a new series just like they did
with the expanse
but they'd never show run the expanse
navarre shankar was the showrunner of
the expanse and they could do something
similar with stargate could brad wright
come back as the showrunner as a manager
as the captain steering the ship in the
right direction
hawke and mark here can come on and push
that into a new direction and create
something
more along the lines of what amazon are
hoping for but that doesn't necessarily
mean that brad won't be involved the
only thing that concerns me about that
is that i would have thought we'd have
heard something by now i do genuinely
believe they would approach a showrunner
first and then go into developing the
new series afterwards but they seem to
be doing it the wrong way around now
that might just be that they're keeping
their cards close to their chest the
brad right was always going to be the
showrunner um and they've just kept it
quiet from what i'm being told amazon
are quite a secretive organization they
don't like to share lots of information
we've actually seen that with the new
lord of the rings rings of power series
that when one person a couple of years
ago that was being consulted on the
project came out and told people a few
little bits and to be honest he didn't
tell you much
they immediately sacked him and cut him
off from the project this is though
obviously purely conjecture purely my
opinion but if brad wright is actually
being lined up to be the showrunner and
he already knows it he wouldn't be able
to say it publicly i actually think brad
wright's script is dead even just a few
weeks ago um joseph melosi said that the
script is still very much in play and
being knocked around amazon i think that
that's actually no longer true i don't
think brad wright's script has any
chance of ever being made but that is
again just my opinion
but what i'm being told is amazon very
very much want this to go in a different
more modern
direction
i think they're looking at what kurtzman
did with star trek and they go in that's
what we want for star game we want it to
feel very much like stargate still like
star trek still feels like star trek but
to go in a slightly different direction
to change 20 percent of it to make it
feel more modern and more in line with
what tv audiences expect today so i
think that's where we're at right now i
think that mark fergus and hawk ogsby
are being brought in to
take the show in that direction but that
doesn't necessarily mean brad's
involvement in stargate is dead and to
be honest i think they'd be insane not
to try and involve brad in some way
remembering that his actual production
company produced sgu and sga
brad wright for me in lots of ways is
stargate and if you want somebody to
come in somebody that knows the project
inside and out and that we already know
can show run brad wright is the obvious
choice he would be desperate i imagine
to do this and he doesn't seem like the
sort of person that would get very
precious about it i don't think he would
be bothered that mark and hawke are
going in and
possibly trying to develop something new
i think he would probably work with
those two guys very very happily but
this is only my opinion i'd love to know
what you guys think get in the comments
tell me do you think brad wright's
project is dead do you think the script
will never happen do you think too much
time has gone by at the end of the day
if they were going to use brad's script
wouldn't they have done it by now
let's get in the comments tell me
exactly what you think guys as you
always do and if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit the
bell notification if you enjoy the
content please consider hitting the join
button
and becoming a fully fledged sidetracker
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you soon
[Music]
you